How many years
Have you been doing this?
Ten years.
The whole thing has been
just incredibly gratifying.
Some time ago I said
you know we give these scholarships
but I want to meet the students.
The Brown scholarship
has just been so impactful in
my education and overall
in my life.
I think that me,
as well as other students
with financial insecurity,
even little things like textbooks can be
make or break for students
being able to be successful
in their classes.
I'm a physiology major and
minoring in Health and Human values
which is an honors college minor.
And I hope to go to Medical School.
After graduation I hope to
pursue law school.
This is a wonderful
connection so that they get
to meet you and know what you
want to do and make the world
a better place.
That's what its all about.
Certainly.
And the nicest things are the notes
that we get from some
of these students who we have
given scholarships to.
They will keep us up to date on
what they are doing.
They may travel out of the country
Arch will get notes and emails
from so-and-so
who is in some distant land
and it's very very gratifying.
So it's sort of like the gift that
keeps on giving.
Absolutely.
You pay it forward as they say.
I remember one year, a woman
came up to Arch and me and said
you know my daughter has been
awarded a scholarship from your
endowment fund. When I am able,
I am going to do the same thing
for other students at the U of A.
Just the idea of our joy of giving
being passed on to someone else,
through our actions, to me
says the whole story.
One thing that I would suggest
to anyone considering it is
just do it!
We are very very appreciative
of what you do for the University
and I can't think of a better
return on investment than
investing in our students.
Thank you so much
for that, its been really
impactful. I would just like to
say thank you again.